Daniel is in San Diego hi Daniel welcome
to the Dave Ramsey show hey thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up my wife and I were
recently approached by a couple whom we
met at church they told us about Amway
and the worldwide group which is in the
business to train and educate
independent business owners to be
successful in their Amalie business now
I know Amway is not a scam so to speak
but I do have major concerns based on
the fact that there's just so much
negative press on Amway on the internet
so I mean I can totally meet someone for
the first time tell them about I'm Way
and they'll probably do a Google search
on Amway and find a bunch of negative
press on it so although I'm we might be
a good opportunity do you feel a bad
idea based on the fact that there's so
many people against it no there's so
many people against everything it is
multi-level marketing in general is very
polarizing and so any multi-level
marketing group that you got involved in
you would find very very negative things
and then the people that are involved
are almost cult-like in their enthusiasm
for it so it's there's nobody kind of in
the middle that's just kind of like yeah
nobody does that everybody's got a
negative opinion or a positive opinion
and that's what you're going to run into
and so the thing is you what you've got
to decide is what you want to do with
your life the mistakes sometimes people
make getting into multi-level is that
they're sold the dream so to speak and
they get into multi-level just for the
money and and you don't want to do that
you always wanted to pick your career
based on is it a fit for you and then go
live your life
appropriately now I have friends that
have been in probably have five friends
or more that make a million dollars a
year or more or have made that in the
past in multi-level but they are very
promotional individuals they're very
driven they are they have evolved into
excellent recruiters and managers of
large numbers of people that turnover
frequently the the nature of the
multi-level is to make money to make
real money like six figures and beyond
you have to be a master recruiter
motivator trainer of salespeople you are
constantly adding because they turn over
like underwear I mean it's got a huge
turnover ratio and so you've got to be
really really good at recruiting and
training salespeople in mass ongoing and
if you can do that you can make good
money in multi-level and if you get in
one that the product line is actually
solid then there's no shame in it but
the the the you know but but all of us
have been approached by someone who
would not take no for an answer and and
they damaged their relationship with you
so you've got to have a little class
about it if you're gonna be in it
because for instance I'm not in
multi-level and I'm highly successful
and I'm not getting in multi-level and
so you know for you to treat me like I'm
some kind of an idiot because I won't
join your thing is gonna damage our
relationship agreed
are you there yes I'm here okay I mean
and so that you know you got to think
about how you're going to approach it
and then the second thing is are you
looking to be a sales manager is that
what you want do with your life and
there's nothing wrong with that I mean I
if that's if that's motivating to you
and you think that's going to be fun and
you you're a real people person and you
get energy from people then you're going
to enjoy that but but if you you know if
you're an accountant and a high detail
person and a highly introverted you're
going to really struggle with this
got it so that's what you're looking for
and I am NOT an endorser of multi-level
and I sure don't think they're for
everyone
they're for a select few people who
choose to go that route and do will do
very very well that way it most of them
are pretty crummy part-time jobs and
they're often pitched as a part-time job
but in general of the concept I'm not a
fan but it there are parts of it that
are legitimate and I will admit that and
say that you know again I have friends
that are legitimate in those businesses
and have done very very well so hope
that helps you open phones at Triple
Eight 8 to 5 5 2 to 5 by the way Emily
folks pretty much invented that so the
legal version of you know they're always
the detractors always the trolls always
call it a pyramid scheme it's not a
pyramid scheme by definition it's
network marketing and but to equate that
to my business or to a traditional
business model is absurd and that's you
know you people that have drunk the
kool-aid and you get all pissed off if
anybody questions the veracity of your
little endeavor and so just calm down
and be a normal human and treat other
people with respect and you'll be all
right